- You've noticed on your
That's because
you'll be choosing
between round bar
and metal grates
sourced from this quarry.
There's plenty of it out there.
You'll have to choose
which is the better option.
And as if that
wasn't hard enough,
today you'll be using these.
Gentlemen, you will have
four hours in this round.
There will be no design period.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your four hours starts now.
I'm grabbing the
large piece of steel,
because the other piece of steel
looked too skinny and small.
I didn't want to
have to forge well.
Thank you.
See, that's the
beauty of this--
even though you're in
competition with each other,
the sportsmanship,
the camaraderie
that you have as bladesmiths.
It's beautiful to
see that Brandon
is getting some of that round
bar for Christoph and Wade.
Forge is over there.
I'm going to make a drop point
hunter because I believe it's
a good design for chopping.
It has a lot of meat
behind the edge.
What inspires me when I'm
making blades is my imagination.
I enjoy reading and
sci-fi-type movies,
and you can make those
instruments and use them.
Brendon is really
having a hard time
getting his fire started.
Oh my God.
You'll get it.
Son of a [bleep]
It's already 20 minutes
into this competition
and one of our bladesmiths
doesn't have a fire,
and that is a huge problem.
I look around,
every other competitor
I started the hammer work.
If I can't get
this fire going, I
believe even my youngest boy's
going to give me hell about it.
I can't believe this.
It would be nice to
see him kind of pile
a little bit more coal
on there, just make
a little vent hole for itself.
That hot flame is moving
out through one section
heating that core.
My main goal
today is not to cry.
[bleep]
Bust that paper up a
little bit if you can.
It's wound up tight.
Look at this.
Wade is actually
taking time off to help
Brandon get his fire started.
Teamwork works.
Look at that.
Bladesmiths, 90
minutes has elapsed.
Brandon coming along great.
Started a little bit
behind everybody else.
Finally starting to get down to
that tang and hammer on that.
My fire is doing
really well now.
So I figure I'll go ahead
and power through, catch up
because I lost a lot of time.
Oh.
I just burnt my blade in half.
I'm going to
[bleep]-ing-ing lose it.
I just want to
kick the fire over
and just [bleep]-ing leave.
Out here with the
lighting like it
is, is it more
difficult to judge
the temperature of your steel?
Absolutely.
As the sun comes out
and it goes away,
everything is dependent
on the lighting.
I'm an extremely
competitive person.
I do not like to lose.
I'm getting new steel
and starting over.
I started my new blade,
and the first thing
is running through my mind
is not overheating it.
I'm not going to cry.
I don't care what happened.
I don't care how many
times I messed up.
I'm not going to burn
my blade again because I
have to turn something in.
I can't just quit.
One of my concerns
here is he's been
hammering that when it's cold.
If he keeps hammering
on cold steel like that,
he could develop cracks.
Bladesmiths, you
only have 60 minutes.
Don't worry about that clock.
There's an hour left, and
I'm trying to catch up.
Matt's got a blade forged out.
Wade's blade is looking
pretty nice as well.
I believe I can get it done,
but it definitely won't be
the blade that I planned to do.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, drop your tools.
This forging round is over.
My blades a chopper.
It's gonna chop.
It is gonna break?
Maybe.
Bladesmiths,
welcome to the forge.
You cold forged signature
blades in your signature style.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Brandon, you're up.
Please present your
work to the judges.
Brandon, a bit of a
rough shape as it sits.
There's a lot of cracking.
I like the drop that
you have over here.
It feels like a good
slashing weapon.
But overall, thank
you for persevering
through that heat and that sun.
Good job.
Thank you.